las competencias de los juegos olímpicos
de tokio ya entregan sus primeras
medallas el ecuatoriano richard antonio
cara pasa alcanzó la gloria olímpica en
el circuito fuji en ciclismo de ruta
tenemos información desde japón
en australia miles de personas
protestaron en melbourne y en sydney un
día después de que las autoridades
anunciaron una posible extensión de los
bloqueos por kobe 19 la gente salió sin
mascarilla y hubo enfrentamientos con la
policía y arrestos tenemos reportes
desde melbourne
y hoy continúan en francia las
movilizaciones contra el pase sanitario
por segundos sábados consecutivos
sectores de la población rechazan la
obligatoriedad del certificado de
vacunación para ingresar a
establecimientos de ocio y otros sitios
públicos en el país
una feliz mañana del sábado mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comienzan las
noticias de france 24
iniciamos el informativo con noticias de
japón tras una emotiva inauguración de
los juegos olímpicos de tokio este
viernes ya se empezaron a entregar los
oros en ciclismo de ruta el ecuatoriano
richard antonio carapaz alcanzó la
gloria olímpica en el circuito fuji para
los detalles vamos a la ciudad
anfitriona con nuestra enviada especial
natalia ruiz natalia buen día y cómo fue
el triunfo de cara paz y mexico ya se
hizo un bronce con tiro con arco
así es ha sido un buen día para los
latinoamericanos primero con ese título
olímpico para richard a cara paz en esta
en esta prueba de ciclismo de ruta de
234 kilómetros muy difícil con ese clima
de altas de temperaturas pero allí con
un espectacular monte fuji como telón de
fondo y bueno pues el ecuatoriano supo
lograr manejar esta carrera que era
bastante larga que tenía al menos 55
ascensos y a unos 6 kilómetros de la
meta pues él logró escaparse en
solitario y pues consagrarse la medalla
de plata fue para el belga good girls
mientras que el bronce fue para el
esloveno tadej ponga char por echar
quien justamente el domingo ganó su
segundo tour de francia de forma por año
consecutivo y bueno con esta medalla de
cara paz pues ya ecuador cuenta con tres
medallas olímpicas dos de ellas de oro
en su historia en la participación de
este país en en las olimpiadas y bueno y
que otros países destacaron en las
últimas horas con el oro olímpico
bueno pues justamente antes de hablarle
del oro olímpico porque si usted lo
mencionaba méxico también se llevó una
medalla de bronce en la prueba de tiro
con arco por equipos fueron alejandra
valencia y luís álvarez a quien quienes
se alzaron con esta presea tras vencer a
turquía también primera medalla esta vez
también de bronce para francia quien
abre su medallero en duda en la
categoría de menos a 60 kilos gracias a
luca merece una sorpresa esta medalla y
primera medalla de oro esta vez para los
anfitriones los japoneses también en
judo - 60 kilos fue una guasa takato él
ayudó acá de 28 años quien se quedó con
esta presea dorada así que muy buen
comienzo para los japoneses
allí consagrándose en el étnico nippon
budokan que es además el templo de las
artes marciales aquí en japón a veces
natalia y cambiamos de tema vamos a
vietnam hanoi inició hoy sábado otros 15
días de confinamiento para combatir la
propagación del nuevo corona virus que
empeora por la variante del está más de
4,6 millones de habitantes se quedarán
en casa y las reuniones de más de dos
personas quedan prohibidas la orden se
dio la noche anterior sin previo aviso
por un aumento súbito de contagios en
las últimas 48 horas y es que este
sábado fueron 5200 positivos frente a
sólo 1500 en todo el 2020
hay protestas en australia miles de
manifestantes se congregaron contra los
cierres para contener la propagación del
hobbit 19 en las ciudades más grandes
del país
melbourne y sídney en la capital de
nueva gales del sur hubo arrestos luego
de enfrentamientos con la policía en los
que un grupo de personas arrojó objetos
a los agentes montadas la gente salió a
la calle sin mascarilla violando la
prohibición de aglomeraciones un día
después de que las autoridades hablarán
de que las restricciones podrían
permanecer vigentes hasta octubre más
información desde melbourne y con
nuestro corresponsal
camilo montoya
las protestas en sídney y melbourne
fueron masivas cientos de personas se
tomaron las calles para manifestarse en
contra de las restricciones impuestas
por los gobiernos estatales debido al
rebrote de la variante delta de kobe 19
en el caso de sydney la ciudad completa
ya un mes en confinamiento en melbourne
vive su quinto confinamiento desde que
inició la pandemia y el tercero este año
en estas manifestaciones hubo
alteraciones del orden público y la
policía hizo uso de la fuerza en sydney
57 personas fueron capturadas y se
impartieron 90 multas por violar las
medidas sanitarias en melbourne seis
personas fueron capturadas y se
impartieron 74 multas
sídney en las últimas 24 horas registró
163 casos nuevos de kobe lo que llevó a
la ciudad a tener mil 703 casos activos
en melbourne tiene una situación
diferente con menos casos en las últimas
24 horas registró 12 casos nuevos y el
estado de victoria tiene 169 casos
activos las autoridades ahora temen que
estas aglomeraciones estas
manifestaciones eleven el número de
casos tanto en sydney como en melbourne
y en francia también hay manifestaciones
hoy contra las medidas para prevenir la
propagación de kobe 19 se trata del
segundo fin de semana consecutivo de
protestas y llega luego de la
implementación de la exigencia del pase
sanitario para acceder a lugares de ocio
el gobierno busca contener la cuarta ola
del virus agravada por la variante del
taa dominante en el país el presidente
del consejo científico de francia jean
françois delfraissy y advirtió que el
regreso a la normalidad podría demorarse
hasta el año 2023 informe de manuel a
cano
el retorno a la tan ansiada normalidad
podría tardar mucho más de lo pensado es
la opinión del presidente del consejo
científico de francia quien advierte que
el aumento de los casos cuestiona que
las personas puedan volver a sus
actividades de manera ordinaria este año
el retorno a la normalidad no es ahora
podría ser en 2022 o 2023
las declaraciones de jones o adelfas y
sean en el momento en el que el pase
sanitario fue aprobado por el parlamento
francés y pone en duda la efectividad de
la medida el científico asegura que aún
con el certificado como requisito y las
discotecas éstas podrían seguir siendo
un importante foco de contagio en
diversos países europeos con altas tasas
de vacunación más altas que el nuestro
acaban de mostrar que una serie de
contagios importantes habían comenzado
en los clubes nocturnos mientras tanto
muchos franceses se sienten obligados a
vacunarse para poder acceder a lugares
cotidianos como bares restaurantes y
cafés donde el pase sanitario será
pedido desde agosto
no tengo otra opción porque si solo
quiero caminar por la calle vivir lo
mínimo debo estar vacunado en francia se
han aplicado 67 millones de vacunas pero
las infecciones no paran de aumentar un
gran porcentaje se debe a la variante
delta
en agosto francia se enfrentaría a
50.000 casos por día
estos son los retos inmediatos de un
país que atraviesa el inicio de una
cuarta ola de contagios a futuro según
el asesor de gobierno el desafío será la
convivencia de dos mundos uno de países
ricos con poblaciones altamente
vacunadas y otro de naciones menos
favorecidas donde la inmunidad de rebaño
seguirá siendo un sueño lejano
a 125 ascendió la cifra de víctimas
mortales por las lluvias e inundaciones
en india mientras que equipos de
búsqueda y rescate siguen intentando
hallar más sobrevivientes entre los
escombros y las casas sumergidas según
expertos el estado de maharashtra en el
oeste del país registró la mayor
cantidad de precipitaciones en 40 años
y una manifestación del orgullo lgtb más
está convocada para hoy en budapest se
trata de una jornada de celebración pero
que este año está marcada por la
protesta en rechazo a la aprobación por
parte del gobierno húngaro de una
legislación considerada como anti lg
vete y comas y porque esta semana
viktor orbán anunció que va a convocar a
un referéndum este año para que la
ciudadanía decida si las escuelas deben
enseñar o no sobre homosexualidad y
asuntos transgénero
y no se pierda esta tarde a las 18 y 5
horas de bogotá quito lima la entrevista
que nuestro equipo en brasil le realizó
al ex presidente luiz inácio lula da
silva este es un avance de lo que verá
quizá información un presidente de la
república que ya tenía información
porque el commit empezó en china y pasó
por una parte de europa debería haber
preparado a los científicos brasileños
podría haber reunido al ministro de
salud ya los secretarios de sanidad de
cada estado crear un comité de crisis
crear un protocolo nacional para que las
personas recibiese en la misma
información oficial basada en un
criterio científico por lo contrario él
no creo nada de eso se peleó con los
gobernadores con los alcaldes con los
laboratorios con la agencia que autoriza
los medicamentos se peleó con la cámara
de diputados con el senado con la corte
suprema se peleó con todo el mundo
entonces hoy en brasil estamos
recogiendo el resultado de la
incompetencia de un genocida donde
estamos cayendo hoy 1 brightview el
resultado sigue con nosotros
[Música]